if you thought the wait for Star Wars
Episode eight couldn't get any longer
than I have some bad news the
science-fiction film has been pushed to
December 15 to 20 17 six months after it
was originally supposed to come out on
May 26 2017 episode 8 is being written
and directed by loopers rain Johnson in
a press release disney announced that
star wars episode 8 is still in
pre-production but principal photography
is scheduled to begin next month in
London rain Johnson also confirmed the
news in a tweet referencing the classic
Star Wars album Christmas in the stars
the force awakens which came out last
month proved to be a surprise box office
success an indie title with a modest
budget that came out of nowhere to
capture imaginations around the world
just kidding it's the biggest domestic
release of all time raking in 861
million dollars and the third biggest
worldwide release with 1.88 seven
billion dollars in an interview with the
los angeles times last month Star Wars
rider Lawrence Kasdan suggested that
episode 8 and 9 might differ from what
he and JJ abrams made with the force
awakens these movies will all be so
different rain Johnson is a friend of
mine he's going to make some weird thing
if you've seen rains work you know it's
not gonna be like anything that's ever
been in Star Wars you couldn't have
three more different people than JJ rain
and Colin those movies will have the
Star Wars saga as their basis but
everything else will be different does
that mean ray could travel back into the
past about sire Luke Skywalker and
become Darth Vader in a confusing but
ultimately satisfying looper like time
travel paradox well no one is said that
isn't happening so maybe taking the
place of episode 8 may release date is
pirates of the caribbean dead men tell
no tales it's no star wars but hopefully
this in rogue one will hold you over
until the war among the stars returns
it's not the best news but at least we
have video games to tide us over in the
meantime
you